Some decisions or major decisions and
also there are a lot of small decisions
that we don't make that they tax our
minds.
They drain our energy.
They create a lot of anxiety and
nervousness and mental torment because
we don't take care of it.
We decide not to decide which is the
decision.
Deciding to decide to act
is a major,
major challenge for all of us at
different points in different areas of
our lives and there are things that
happened to us along the way.
Experiences that we have that prevent us
from working through the mental block of
acting,
of doing those things that we know we
ought to do.
And so what I want you to think about is
what is there that you know you need to
do that you want to do this,
but for some reason or another,
you've been holding back for some reason
or another.
You just have not been able to gather
your nerves or be able to work through
all the procrastinating or putting it
off or justifying or blaming some reason
or another.
You just haven't done it
and you know you ought to do this.
You really want to do this,
but you don't know why you haven't done
it.
Anybody know what I'm talking about?
Raise your hand.
Believes okay,
then I've got company here this evening.
I'm not talking to myself now.
First,
all we know that this is not easy
because in order to begin to reinvent
your life,
you've got to make a conscious,
deliberate,
determined effort.
Sure.
That you really have got to put all of
yourself into it.
It's very challenging to add to do those
things that at times when you're looking
at him,
you say,
I know I need to do this,
but I don't feel like it.
I don't want to do it.
I know I need to do it yet.
Leave me alone.
No,
I don't want to do it.
So what do we do?
What are those things that cause us to
do like that?
I think that among the things that
prevent us from acting,
it's the fear of failure and if you've
already failed,
you don't want to fail again.
The pain of that,
the disappointment,
the fear of loss is another thing
because many times when we do those
things that we know we need to do,
we feel that we might lose somebody that
we love very much and care about.
We don't want to hurt anybody.
Many of us don't act because we want
other people's approval.
We want everybody to like us and to
accept us.
And that's not possible.
Many of us don't do the things that we
want to do and don't act because of lack
of self confidence.
We don't believe enough in ourselves.
I have friend who's been working on a
job where she's miserable,
talented,
want to go to another place that she can
do what she wants to do and make the
kind of money that she would like to
make and have had some offers.
But because of her fear and how the lack
of self confidence,
uh,
things might not work out,
she won't take a chance on yourself.
So there she is spending eight hours a
day,
five days a week,
and she's miserable.
She hates to go to work.
They're not paying on what she's
watching knows it,
but yet instill,
she won't do that,
which she knows she much to do and it's
wearing out that a lot of people that
their jobs are making them sick because
they want to act.
You check out the absenteeism and the
people that are depressed.
You see,
I'm coming to work angry.
How you doing?
No,
just leave me alone.
It's not even 9:00 yet.
You're talking about good morning.
That days you got to work.
You want to just keep driving past a
job.
You know you don't want to stop because
it's not in sync with who you are,
but you haven't acted.
Have another friend.
He's got brilliant.
He's a business consultant.
He helped a lot of people get their
business started and people come to him
because they know he's knowledgeable,
but this guy wants to start his own
business now.
He's very smart.
He can do it.
Everybody believes in it except him and
he's so smart.
He's talked himself out of the well,
the numbers aren't right,
so there are many reasons why we don't
act.
There are other things though that
affect us is that not wanting to take
personal responsibility.
We want somebody else to do it,
and we,
many times we pick up our inability to
do certain things from people that we
love,
people that we admire,
we identify with them and we live in the
context of their ideas,
their opinions and their life patterns.
We buy into it unconsciously.
My mother is a pack rat.
She keeps everything.
She doesn't throw anything away and I
have unconsciously picked that up.
Now my mother never said,
let me show you how to keep everything
less than just clutter things.
I unconsciously picked that up many
times.
Unconsciously.
We tried to honor the people we love by
being like them.
By the same token,
I realized something about myself when I
had some major decisions to make and I
find myself acting like my mother.
My mother mother's the kind of person
that when she has a problem with one of
the other foster that she adopted,
she won't confront them.
She will call me last.
Why don't you tell lender to move?
She's lazy.
She won't go to work.
She runs the street all day and then she
comes home and wants to sleep all day
and I think she's doing droughts.
I said,
but Mama,
why don't you tell Linda that I bought
the house for you.
I told you when she wanted to come home,
don't let a grown person come there and
take care of them.
You let her in will after all she is my
Mama.
Then you handle that.
When I tell her to leave,
she say,
mama say I can say Mama,
can I say and you tell her yes,
and then you call me and say she's still
here.
Why worry me with this?
So Mama hasn't developed the courage to
act on that.
Some people won't act until there's a
crisis situation.
When Linda stopped stealing from Mama
and took us social security check to get
some drugs,
mama got some cars to say get outta here
would ever come back,
but she wouldn't do it until then and
say,
we don't have to wait until a crisis
situation.
I have a friend that had been having a
challenge with losing weight.
Both of us had been dealing with that
challenge and for the past 40 years is
always seemed like weighed over 235
pounds and so he said,
man,
I just can't lose weight.
I'm big boned it.
I say,
I've never seen any fat skeleton.
No,
you need to act on your health.
You can change this.
Well,
you don't have to go to your grave fat.
We're all digging early grades without
teeth.
We don't have to do this.
They need to have a support group around
m and m peanuts.
You want a support group on something
and throw snickers in there too.
I can tell you about the help we need
with that.
So what happened with bud though,
he became ill a few weeks ago,
so he bought in the last few weeks,
has lost more weight than is ever lost.
Even when we were competing with each
other,
betting a lot of money.
But what happened was bob became
diabetic.
He went into an insulin shock.
He didn't know that he was diabetic,
his blood sugar became high and the
doctor said to him,
you are diabetic.
You're going to have to have insulin
shots every day.
You're gonna have to change your diet
and let me tell you what's going to
happen if you don't do what we tell you
to do.
Number one,
there's a possibility that you can
become an amputee.
Number two,
you can go blind.
Three,
you can become impotent bugs.
They help me
when?
When,
when,
when bro got to jail and guys say,
can I do to be saved?
You want one my peanut butter and jelly
sandwiches?
No,
I said,
but I can't believe you're eating
vegetables.
You're exercising,
jogging in place.
Now,
he had the ability to do,
do it before,
but there are some people.
It takes that kind of crises to bring
them into reality in order for them to
act in their own best interests.
Some people have to hit rock bottom in
order to ride.
I don't know why you want to begin to
look out on your life and what you want
for you,
and I think that when we began to focus
in the area of what does it take for us
to act,
I think we can say events can inspire us
to act at that particular event in his
life circumstances.
Friend of mine,
he wanted to do something and he just
did not have the motivation and the
drive and the confidence within himself,
but as circumstances change overnight
through an acquisition of a company that
he worked for,
he lost his job.
Through the inspiration of desperation,
he had to act
the life also of things that can inspire
us,
that see,
we don't have the courage,
and that's what it takes.
Courage.
It takes guts to do that.
What you know you need to do.
If you don't have the courage to act
live,
many times we'll move on you and make
you at live will whoop your butt so bad.
You will be so miserable.
You will get so much how you say,
yes,
I will do it.
What do you want me to do?
Take me
friend of mine say,
I can't stop smoking.
Dr Said Sam Axelrod,
you have emphysema.
Sam never picked up another cigarette
and said,
look of stupid people smoking.
Sam,
you did it for 35 years.
How can you talk about people?
While I was different,
I'm trying to help them.
They don't
do the same thing I did,
but be compassionate now.
Isn't an interesting how quickly we
forget,
so I'm saying that look at something in
your life.
It might be just writing a letter to
somebody to say thank you.
It might be just to apologize to
somebody.
I had a confrontation and the penobscot
building with the security guard there.
He responded to me what I perceived as a
negative way and he and I engaged in an
argument.
I did not like the way I handled that.
I avoided going through the front door
for a long time because I didn't want to
face it.
Finally I decided to act and I went up
to him and said,
I want to apologize to you for the way
in which I handled this argument we had.
The other day.
I was wrong.
I hope you accept my apology.
He said I do.
And I said,
thank you very much.
I felt relieved.
Now when you decide to act,
it's not always going to be like that.
A friend of mine did some work for me.
It was below par to say the least.
I knew that this guy was capable of
doing better work.
I knew that he also had a fragile ego,
so I was trying to think of what is the
most sensitive way in which I can share
this information with him because I
wanted him to do my work over.
I was going to pay him for what he did,
but I needed my work done right.
But I was afraid that I would hurt his
feelings.
So I was very,
very meticulous and how I approached him
and I said,
let me share this with you.
You know,
I care about you and that you are very
talented and gifted person and you and I
both know that what you have given me is
not a true reflection of your talents
and abilities.
And I'm saying,
let's go back in the studio and do this
again.
And he said to me,
I'm going to forget you ever said that.
I was wiped out.
He never spoke to me again.
Now when you decide to act,
you're going to have some people like
that.
We're no longer friends.
I lost sleep over that.
Ladies and gentlemen,
I said,
I can't believe that.
I remember setting up one night looking
at the phone.
I said,
I got call him.
Said,
no,
that's it.
No,
forget that.
I see men looking.
We've been knowing each other too long
to allow this to come between us.
He said,
don't call me anymore.
And Hung Up.
And then I wanted to think about how,
what can I do to make it up to him?
And then something came to me less.
What do you have to prove?
So many things.
We don't do it because in fact,
we want people to like us.
That's unnecessary losses in life.
When you decide acting in your best
interest,
you're going to lose some friends.
Everybody's not going to approve of you.
There are some people that work like
you.
Who Do you think you are?
You are arrogant.
What do you think you can do?
You think you'd get away with that?
You're selfish.
Thanks,
I got that.
It's my life,
and so what I'm saying to you is that as
you begin to look out on your life,
this is challenging.
This is not easy acting,
so one of the things that we can begin
to do to harness our will,
number one,
you've got to bring it out and look at
it.
You got to take the power out of it.
You've got to it to the truth,
and the truth is that it has no power
over you,
so write down something you want to act
on,
but for some reason that you've been
holding back and look at it.
The next thing is ask yourself the
question,
is it helping you to continue to put it
off?
If it's an asset for you to continue to
procrastinate,
then continue to do that,
but if it's a liability for you,
if it's causing you some mental and some
emotional challenges or perhaps a
financial problem,
look at that.
Examine that for what it is.
Next step.
Ask Yourself,
what's blocking you?
What's preventing you from acting?
Why don't you have the courage to handle
that?
Why won't you face that?
What are you running away from?
What kind of avoidance behavior are you
engaged in?
Next is what is the worst thing that can
happen when you take action?
So I looked at that and I said,
what's the worst thing can happen when I
tell him this?
He can say,
I don't like you any did.
Now what happened?
I experienced that.
I looked at that,
I saw that.
And guess what?
Ladies and gentlemen,
I didn't dye
my feelings were hurt a little bit.
I lost some sleep about it and sometimes
I think about it when I drive past his
house,
but I'm still here.
It's uncomfortable,
but it's okay.
It doesn't bother me anymore.
I've gotten used to it now.
So what is the worst thing that can
happen?
I want you to visualize that experience,
that feel,
the nervousness and the discomfort and
the more you run into in your mind the
less power that it will have.
Next is how will you feel after taking
this action?
I felt a sense of personal achievement
when I faced somebody that has been my
mentor for years and for years that was
something I wanted to tell him and I
didn't have the courage to tell him
because it was always I was a student.
He wants to teach her.
It was always.
I looked up to him and admired him and
held him in high esteem and I was always
grateful and thankful for the impact
that he had on my life.
And I loved him so much.
I didn't have the courage to say to him,
please stop drinking so much you an
alcoholic,
you need help.
I didn't have the courage because I was
afraid that he might not like me.
I was afraid that he might be hurt and
crushed,
that we would no longer be friends.
I didn't want to jeopardize what we had.
I loved him a great deal and I didn't.
I didn't know how this would affect our
relationship and I didn't even want him
to know that I knew that he was an
alcoholic and so I was a cow,
spineless and the name of law.
I did it to justify to myself to stop
from helping somebody that I loved from
dying.
I said,
I love him so much.
I just can't tell him this.
I don't even know how he would handle
it.
To know that I know that he's an
alcoholic,
and finally after years I developed the
courage to face my teacher,
my mentor who has molded me,
who looks at me now and wanted to do
what I'm doing now and did not do.
It.
Came at a different time and it wasn't
time for what he brought and he's living
through me and I had to face this man
who's been like a father to me.
It's,
I got to tell you something.
You've got a problem.
I love you very much.
Please stop drinking.
You're killing yourself.
It's not just social.
You do it every day.
You need help and whatever.
I can do to support you in that.
I will please stop,
and he looked at me and I had no idea
what,
how he was going to handle that at first
that was like,
I dare you,
and we just looked at each other
and then I reached out to embrace him
and we never ever embrace man.
Macho never hugged me.
I hugged him and he just stood there
with his arms straight.
He couldn't raise his arms to hug me
back and he was shocked and after he got
over the initial shock when you could
bring him stuff to speak,
to maintain his composure because he
could never afford to let me,
his students see him vulnerable or admit
that I was right.
He said,
I'll be seeing you.
I said,
yes sir.
tell you why.
Be by the house to see the car before I
leave.
And when he walked away,
at first I was very depressed about it
and I said,
well,
maybe it wasn't my place to do this and
that.
You know,
when you act,
you're going to have some second
thoughts.
And then I said,
no,
no.
I did what I felt I did it because I
feel very strongly about this
and fortunately he called me back a few
weeks later and left word with the
answering service les,
Les Brown.
I just want to say thank you
and hung up.
I was a good feeling.
When we look out on our lives,
you asked the question,
what are you going to do?
Look at as you think about this that you
know need to handle,
what are you going to do?
And then write down three strong reasons
on why you know you must take action
and being explicit and descriptive in
your reasons because your reasons have
power.
Your reasons will drive you when you
have doubt,
when your faith becomes weak,
your reasons will fortify your faith.
When you have an inner conversation,
say no,
don't do that.
Your reasons will become your rod and
your staff to convert you,
to take you through those challenging
moments,
so write down your reasons and what you
will find,
but when you decide to act,
when you decided to take life on,
and let me warn you,
it can be painful.
It will be uncomfortable and that's
where the growth is.
When you're uncomfortable,
when you're stretching up,
when you're taking a life bother collar,
you're going to get thrown to the ground
again and again and again,
but when you had the termination and you
know that what you're doing is right,
it gives you your life.
It gives us special meeting and power to
you.
You will have some power from on high.
You will discover some things about
yourself.
Then we'll begin to electrify your
personality.
You'll begin to discover some things
about you,
but you don't know you've got.
When you put yourself in that type of
challenging situation,
repeat after me please.
I can go into action
on anything in my life.
Nothing is stopping me but me.
No challenge in my life
has any power over me.
Here's something that Howard Thurman
wrote on the decision to act.
He said it's a wondrous thing,
that a decision to act releases energy
and the personality for days on end,
a person may drift along without much
energy,
having no particular sense of direction
and having no will to change.
Then something happens to alter the
pattern.
It may be something very simple and
inconsequential in itself,
but it stabs awake.
It alarms,
it disturbs in a flash.
One gets a vivid picture of one self and
it passes.
The result is decision,
Sharp,
definitive decision and the wake of the
decision,
yes.
Even as a part of the decision itself,
energy is released.
The act of decision sweeps all before it
and the life of the individual maybe
changed.
When did you decide to make decisions to
act?
You began to access power within you
that will increase your self esteem,
that will increase and enhance your
personal power,
but that puts you in charge of life and
life has a whole new meaning for you as
a sense of personal freedom.
Doesn't mean you're not gonna.
Have any struggles,
doesn't mean that you're not gonna have
any challenges.
Doesn't mean that you're not going to
suffer any defeat.
No,
no,
no.
It doesn't mean bad,
but what it does mean that you're
putting yourself in the position to
grow.
You're putting yourself in line with
your higher calling and your highest
self,
and
that's what life is about.
Thank
you.
This affirmation,
please everybody stand please.
I'm standing up to live
and the challenges in my life.
I'm going to use all of me,
all of my courage,
my faith,
determination,
and any help and support that I can give
anyone
to realize that greatness
together we can shake somebody's hand on
your right and left and say,
you got what it takes.